here with reaction Fox News contributor
Tulsi Gabbert Tulsi how are you I'm
great Sean how are you hi to everybody
there here everyone doing all right says
hello okay
so Maureen Ed out writes an article Then
followed by USA Today about how the
Biden's uh I think it's pathetic I think
it's uh unconscionable that they won't
recognize their own granddaughter at the
same time you have the Atlantic writing
about how well what the perfect day
would be for Joe to drop out of the race
then we have all these leaks from the
White House that is a nasty vicious vile
temper even towards young age sounds to
me like people on the left are turning
on Joe and maybe this is the beginning
not the end and God help him if he falls
one more time
yeah you know Sean all of these signs
are very telling but you know I I think
that there are actually a lot of
Democrats across the country who like me
feel that today's Democratic party is
completely out of touch with the people
we have the Democrat Elite people in the
Biden Administration pushing this
nonsense saying things like hey the
government should be responsible for
raising your children not you as parents
they are pushing things like censorship
of any speech that they don't like
they're pushing open borders they're
pushing favoring criminals over victims
the list of their Insanity goes on and
on and on I was a Democrat my entire
adult life up until a few months ago
because of their Insanity I could no
longer associate myselves with them and
so they have created this position for
themselves where voters are looking
elsewhere and I just got to say you know
you mentioned no labels in Joe manchin
the Democrats are terrified of this and
I think it's laughable and arrogant that
they're saying oh well how dare he be a
spoiler
they're so entitled they take voters for
granted that they think that they can
just call anyone who stands up against
them as a political opponent for Joe
Biden as a spoiler it's it's it's crazy
voters want options they want to be able
to vote for the best candidate that they
believe can do the job do you see Robert
Kennedy uh do you see Marianne
Williamson do you see Cornell West do
you see Joe manchin uh do you see any
real threat to Joe Biden what about
Gavin Newsom he's been doing a lot of
campaigning recently I had a long
interview with him he says he's
supporting Joe however I believe that
he's probably getting close to 150
000 calls a week telling him he needs to
get in do you agree with that
well on Gavin Newsom I think voters are
smarter than the Democrat a leader
giving them credit for they recognize
that Gavin Newsom has shown through his
record his failed record in California
would be just a younger version of the
Biden administration's same insane
policies that look out for their own
self-serving interests and not the best
interests of the American people and our
country I think poll after poll shows
that voters in this country are looking
for someone other than Joe Biden and his
failed policies to lead this country and
so absolutely they should consider all
the options before them would you ever
consider getting in
uh if there were a way for me to be able
to best serve this country in that
fashion I would
uh would you consider that third party
or No Labels option
uh I'd consider all options put it that
way
wow sounds like somebody's thinking of
getting in this race we'll see uh Tulsi
God we're great to have you as always
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else